it is being called a game changer and
the start of a new era germany
has promised to begin returning the
artifacts known as the benin bronzes
to nigeria next year making it the first
country to do so
germany has a collection of just over 1
000 benin bronzers they're on display in
museums in cologne in dresden
hamburg leipzig and stuttgart now the
sculptures and metal plaques
are from the ancient kingdom of bernin
which is today known as
edor state in southern nigeria the
bronzes were looted by british soldiers
in 1897 and sold to museums in north
america and europe
the largest collection of the bronzes is
held by the british
museum nigeria has been trying to get
back the bronzes for
decades without success but momentum has
been building over the last few years
with
cores growing ever louder for artifacts
seized during the
colonial era to be returned to their
places of origin
germany's culture minister explained why
berlin had decided to act now she said
quote we are confronting our historic
and moral responsibility
we want to contribute to a common
understanding
and reconciliation with the descendants
of the people
who were robbed of their cultural
treasures during the time
of colonialism close quote
the benin bronzes some of africa's most
prized treasures for decades demands for
their restitution have grown louder
now cultural and political leaders have
agreed to begin
returning the artifacts held in german
museums
by next year
i must admit i cannot believe it but
there was a posit very positive result
and everybody was
agreed to it that the being albanian
bronzes the banin
looted art has to go back to nigeria
so this is this is really great
really great news and a significant
change of heart the bronzes were due to
be showcased at berlin's new
humboldt forum just a few weeks ago the
foundation which currently holds the
bronzes
was reticent about the possibility of
returning
they can be seen in them museums around
the world the benzene bronzers are
exceptional art and when they came to
europe they highlighted a completely new
image of africa as a continent steeped
in history and culture
the benin bronzes are of course part of
the cultural history of nigeria and
benin
but they have also become global
the four thousand artifacts were
plundered from the benin
empire now part of nigeria after a
violent british raid in 1897
they were later sold to museums in
europe and north
america now nigeria will regain
sovereignty over some of these royal and
sacred artworks so central to the
nation's cultural heritage
nigerian partners can decide by
themselves
how this restitution will take
place how this repatriation will take
place
and in case there will looted artwork
will remain in german museums that will
be
their decision that it doesn't become
again a white a white
dialogue nigeria plans to build a museum
in benin city to house the looted
artifacts
we need you know these cultural
properties
as inspiration and that would come with
you know the return would seem for young
people to see because they can't come to
europe they can't visit european
museums you know the only way they would
be able to
to view physically see these uh
mimetic creations is if they were in
nigeria
one leading european historian says her
research
shows that for decades museums
deliberately dragged their feet
on the issue of restitution
[Music]
museum directors tried to buy time they
actually
formulated it in writing as a strategy
they left the problem to the next
generation
that's us now it's clear we can't we
mustn't continue to push it off to the
next generation we have to act
it's not just about ownership but about
a whole new way of thinking
i really think we have to to
to deal with this colonial world and how
we could perhaps become a place of
repair
this is a very very long way
and very complicated but we could try
so it could be a museum could also be a
kind of healing place
even in europe
germany's decision to act marks a
paradigm
shift in the handling of looted
artifacts
and i'm pleased to welcome the
senegalese philosopher professor soliman
bashed yang
on to the program to talk about this he
is currently the director of the
institute of african studies at columbia
university in
new york welcome professor jan lovely to
have you on the program
so this development is being called a
game changer give us your reaction to
the news
that germany will start returning benin
bronzes to nigeria next year
well it is great news indeed because you
you said it
right this is a game changer already
the the decision by the french president
to restitute
certain objects was a groundbreaking
decision but this is a huge huge game
changer
because the benin bronzes have had this
hugely symbolic value yeah professor in
your work you you've talked about that
how the brilliant bronzers are
particularly important tell us what
makes them so special
well uh when they were looted in 1897
in a way europe discovered them more
more broadly
and the benin bronzes really changed
the perception that europeans had of
african art
they were just fascinated by the
sophistication of the work
they were really
stunned astonished at first by
what it meant in terms of mastery
of metal work and in particular
the very sophisticated technique uh
known as
lost wax uh casting
meaning that you you build a figure
in wax and then you pour the melted
metal into it and when it
when it's uh cold it takes the form of
whatever it is that you you
you carved out of wax and
so that's the the a very important
aspect
in the first place that is on the
european side it meant for the
perception of african art
and then there is the fact that the way
in which they were
acquired acquired is really a euphemism
they were
looted they were actually taken by
violence
from uh the the palace of the of the
king of
benin of the kingdom of benin in the
late uh
19th century that's right professor so
so what do you make of
the arguments against restitution right
the most prominent being
the view that the art is safer and
better cared for in
in european and north african museums
excuse me north american
museums than it would be in africa well
let's take these bronzers precisely
let's take these these these bronzers
they were taken from a place where they
were safe they were taken from the
palace of the king
so the first and most prominent
thing to be considered is the fact that
we are talking about righting or wrong
if
that principle is established then
everything
else becomes technical it is normal that
as they developed and they developed
their own
infrastructure for culture for museums
etc
these countries are now asking for the
restitution of the objects
meaning that they have themselves
developed
capacity to keep them to
and they have developed music
professor just hold that thought for a
second because i do want to come back to
something that you've just said you
talked about righting or wrong so there
is of course
the moral and ethical argument right as
you're saying what's what was stolen
should be
returned to its rightful owner but but
beyond that what kind of connection do
africans have
to these objects
well let's take the bronzes all the
plaques
uh the bronze plaques that you had in
the palace of the king
of the king of benin at that time what
do they do what what was their function
they were telling the narrative of the
kingdom
of benin these are
testimonies of what is known as art
court
and this is probably why they are
naturalistic art usually african art
is known to be very symbolic very
abstract and
not really reproducing reality as it is
but a kind of a symbolization of reality
in this particular case you have
mainly naturalistic art because they
tell
the the narrative of the kingdom itself
we know that many of the heads
are heads of kings of beni
so the narrative being told
if you take that with you if you loot it
if you plunder it
it means you are taking the memory of a
particular kingdom
so this is why it is not just the moral
aspect
it is really a way of reconnecting a
memory that has been fragmented it is a
remembering
of the african memory and that is
professor suleiman bashir
diana thank you professor it's been
great having your views on this topic
thank you for having me
we sent our team uh out to get some
reaction from people in nigeria where
the news has been welcomed but
but as you're about to hear there are
some doubts
too do we trust ourselves
some people will surely go there and
loot it and sell it send it back to the
another country that need it
i think the problem is every one of us
not only the government
do we trust ourselves
if we the german are returning it i
think we should ease our assets we
should keep it
i believe they should even return it
back to the very uh edu states
and they should now android i think
there should be a museum there
owned by the federal government and the
people is the assets
so they will take care of it very well
but if you leave it somewhere in lagos
or abuja anybody can go in there and
loot it
and that's the end we're back to square
one
i mean um nigeria being we
we we are we may not be able
because we don't appreciate all those
things but at the same time
is our own then it should be returned
back
to this country and uh we should uh
every individual every state should do
i mean one of the things to keep those
scenes
they they are very important to us they
are more or less like a foundation
to we should keep it our own job needs
to return our hard work
back to nigeria but the issue we have in
nigeria is
security how we can how the government
will be able to protect these
artworks when they are finally resolved
but it's our asset in nigeria we should
have it back that's what that's my own
opinion
firstly naturally one would say if it is
because it belongs to nigeria they
should return it
but to some extent i mean indifference
about it because even when they bring it
what are they going to give it to
because we can be sure the present
government
they are going to return it back to them
they will sell it back to them
so to me does it concern me whether they
return it or they don't return it
but if you look at the benefits of it if
it's going to if it's something that
they will keep in our museums
that our children can have access to you
say okay
it's beneficial but i know that it won't
go to the museum
they are going to sell it back to them
so to some essence i'm
indifferent about it it doesn't concern
me if they are really
willing to do that i think that is
kind from them maybe something has
pricked their conscience
you understand so many things have been
taken from us
as a third world country ignorant people
but it's left for the civilized
to look back and say is it worth it
these are cultural things it has no
meaning to them
these are cultural things so it is nice
if
it has touched their spirit to return it
all i can say that i pray god that it
will
inspire those in power
when these things are returned to work
hard
and take care of it
because it's like a blessing
but to say whether i believe they can do
it i don't know
it's not just the benin bronzers from
nigeria that are wanted by their
rightful owners there is also a claim
from cameroon
from where a special artifact known as
the tange was stolen from a local king
more than a century later it is still in
germany but as our reporter found
not everyone in cameroon is of the view
that it should be brought back
to the country in dwala cameroon prince
coleman dumber the third has been
advocating for the return of the tange
a sculpture stolen from his grandfather
in 1884.
prince dumbay has made this copy of the
tangy and put it on show
in cameroon the original artifact looted
by the germans during the colonial times
is on display at a museum in munich
we have come to meet the prince for an
interview
but his spokesman told us he's not
available at the moment
but we are told that the prince wants
the tangy to be repatriated to cameroon
immediately however not everyone agrees
that tangent should be immediately
returned
princess marilyn dweller bell is an
artist and founder of an art center in
dwala
even though her great grandfather was
executed in 1914 for resisting german
rule
marilyn thinks cameron is not ready to
receive the artifact
the restitution the repatriation
should be a process
that was taken away more than 100 years
ago
it was taken away under very complicated
circumstances
others in dwala also claimed to be the
rightful owners of the tangy
at least one more descendant of a
dweller king has made a claim
on the artifact for marilyn this is a
source of concern
she wants a tangate to be returned but
fears the conditions are currently not
right
if an artifact is returned who should it
be given to
this was not an object that was taken
away from a family this is not an object
that was taken away from an individual
it was looted from a community so who is
going to negotiate
who is going to take charge of it
for local artists like stefan ellundu
who has been on the ad scene for 20
years
the tangy represents more than just
sculpture
he thinks it's a spiritual symbol that
will boast local creativity if it is
brought back
will be a means to inspire the young
generation
most people here want the tangy to be
repatriated
however there is no agreement on when
how
and to who the artifact should be handed
back
you